hello and welcome to the long dear
except not quite long did channel second
channel anymore I am slowly reviving it
too this is our second episode where I
play games or Age of Empires at the
moment and answer your questions today's
question was selected by my patrons I
put a whole bunch of them up they voted
for it and they had a you know picking
between what's it like self-publishing
favorite tropes and stories how to write
a good essay ranking all of the Avatar
episodes and they picked from a bunch of
them my favorite tropes and stories so
that's what I'm going to be talking
about today you know my favorite kind of
few tropes why I like them stories that
kind of have them why I think they work
because I you know there's often like a
difference between tropes that you love
and tropes that really work well and
while I do that I am going to try my
best to focus on a game of Age of
Empires it's just me versus a hard a I
and I am not very good at multitasking I
want to be clear about that so if I if I
do end up kind of screwing up then that
then you know why if I lose it's it's
not on me it's not on me can't be on me
I'm just too distracted talking about
stories not only that I've got my milk
yes this is a glass of milk my friends
gave me he'll for apparently drinking a
glass of milk but with a straw even but
it's normal adults can have milk okay
and I put a poll on Instagram
and on Twitter proving this you tell me
in the comments though is it normal for
a adult devil is it okay for an adult
have just like a glass of milk just
straight milk
alright playing as the huns let's let's
play them first in the Berbers I've got
to be honest I don't really know what
the strengths of the Berbers are but the
Huns are really good at taking down
houses basically huh let's see how I go
oh and they don't have to build houses
which is very abnormal I don't think
there's any other civilization that that
doesn't have to do that and of course
you know to start what is what's your
what's your what are your favorite ropes
hmm what are your favorite tropes you
let me know down in the comments to
start with I guess I'll I'll go through
kind of like you know what I really love
and I love to start with conspiracy
stories like you get me a story where
the enemy is the government or some
cabal of shadowy you know folks who are
trying to plan for the world and I am
just so look where my Abba sheeps there
are my other shapes don't just just go
there and I am I am just all there
because the the story is what they
happen because you you always have there
just like a sensual moment where the
characters figure out the conspiracy and
it's so cool because one of the
characters that you've been following
has been in on it the whole time and I
just love that moment and you can tell
how distracted I am trying to play this
game because I just left my town center
not creating villages which is a crime
in this game
so with that in mind well let's get you
going on some wood and let's get you
build dinner
nice little mill I there's a bunch of
stories that of course you know like how
many stories have you seen that ever
conspiracy and like even really average
shows like designated survivor and I'm
short I'm sorry designated to fire fans
like it's fine it's fine it's just it's
not it's not just in it's just not
anything like gloriously fantastic it's
not the west wing or house of cards but
it's not trying to be in fact it's
trying to be the anti house of cards but
like there's a conspiracy story in that
and that was like the main thing that
kept me watching just cuz I mean it was
good I wasn't the best conspiracy story
but like the x-files I think that was
probably my earliest exposure to it oh
no
I'm so distracted yeah I mean like that
that'll keep me watching that'll that'll
keep me watching as long as it's good
the x-files is of course you know like
this whole series spanning conspiracy
that doesn't make sense half the time by
the end of it but it's it's amazing it's
amazing until the last season they
really screwed that conspiracy story up
which I won't spoil it if you haven't
seen it but then again who has seen all
of the x-files you know like it came out
in the 1990s and what today you know
who's who've seen it these days it's
it's just all ass young uns
no one's no one's seen all the x-files
what are some of my favorite conspiracy
stories I don't know I really don't know
I think I'm really struggling to
remember like fantastic conspiracy
stories off the top of my head apart
from like I really loved the x-files
that was good
all right let's just like standard
Arabia
let's Arabia is just like a map where
there's lots of gold and there's you
know some trees not a huge amount but
yeah cuz I've got enough wood not really
badly time to that but I haven't got
enough wood to sit up farms a little bit
[Music]
just gonna the key is by the way just to
go lots of resources and then hit up to
castle age when you can let's get up
gold so when I played D&D
and I play as when I'm the DM and I'm
I'm the DM a fair amount the players
always talk about how they know you know
that that they know it it'll be my kind
of though that when I'm win under DM
that they will that they know that I
will bring in the conspiracy and that
some it's kind of a trope that one of
the characters they meet is gonna be
part of some conspiracy trying to ruin
the town or ruin the city as fear it's
fair I just I I can't help it I can't
help it
conspiracy stories are just so good I
mean often they're really crap like it's
a pretty cheesy trope love the time but
it just has moments like story baits
that that you know you commonly
associate with
and let's stick them on wood for the
moment just cuz that's that's safe they
know that there's gonna be a conspiracy
story in whatever game they play with me
if I'm in charge of it and the real task
is just figuring out who's gonna betray
them which I mean and I know I know is
is like not that interesting and its own
right but I love telling them like
you've got the the reveal that someone's
been part of the conspiracy and you've
got the moment where if someone figures
it all out and then they're killed
before they can tell anyone and I just I
love those moments they're just so good
I mean in a way house of cards is kind
of you know a conspiracy story from the
point of view of the conspiracists is a
conspiracy in the blacklist which I
thought was pretty cool it's not like
fantastic actually
no it's pretty good it's pretty good as
I as a conspiracy story
okay let's let's get you lot and they
call it the Cabal trying to think of
other conspiracy stories I don't know
what are your favorite conspiracies in I
mean they're pretty common in games like
pink Deus Ex has a conspiracy let's get
out some BMN just because there are
always trying to rush you with a bunch
of cab and I
[Music]
maybe I'll be part of the you know I
actually did a did a video on on class
recently and they were talking about I
talked about kind of like that the
Richard powerful they're not sitting in
dark shadowy rooms like your average
conspiracy going on how shall we screw
over the world today and then people are
like have you not heard of the
Bilderberg conference which was which is
well the Denver conference camera but
the exact name it is but oh it's just
the Bernie got like people going up
let's let's let's get you guys let's get
you guys off there
but what we really is Stables okay what
do they got its they've got a bunch of
bunch of archery ranges couple of
barracks smithy all right so I've got a
nice nice defensive Hill out here I'm
gonna see in the afford to build let's
just build that there because I'll be
coming through that way and that should
be should be enough to kind of just ward
them off for a bit another another trope
that I really love and I've I've
actually mentioned this a couple of
times early so I've sort of implied it
you know is I really love it's a very
specific Trobe I love the father or
mother figure trying to get the child
figure to the border or to safety and
it's got just that and the reason I love
it is
it's gonna mock it out and we'll get you
one stone
because we're gonna want to go into the
castle build castles and I mean that the
examples that I can think of off the top
of my head I really love the the Cara
story in Detroit become human and
there's the Last of Us there's Logan you
know there's a reason that Logan was my
favorite x-men film it's just got that
damn it you guys get in the towers
bloody hell
get stay and stay at the house stay with
him oh I'm so useless
okay well hopefully that should be
enough to kill them oh well this was my
fault
let's let's get all of them on producing
and because they're going he be Scout
they're going really heavy on the
archers I'll go here beyond the scam
scams do really well these are these are
scams that guy that just died he's scam
he does well against arches my arch is
this safe inside my beautiful tower and
I love God those guys to hell with yes
soon but what we really want is we want
to get into the castle age and then we
want to get we want to get basically a
bunch of tonic cavalry out there
great and I don't think they were in the
castle age yet unless I missed it
somehow and we'll get a castle built now
see that just forward up there so
building them on Hills gives them extra
damage so that's why I'm seeing them up
here and we need to get you guys on food
and we'll upgrade that to Elite
skirmisher but need to get a need to get
us I want to get a second castle up as
soon as I can I mean I saw it's also the
story it's not really the story of God
of War but it is very dependent on that
on their father-son dynamic which I
really love
and
okay so there's some gold beer where's
the witch I will check the second we
need more wood God of War you know it
really relies on on that father-son
dynamic and I think in a way it's it's
very familiar you know like it is a
dynamic that everyone understands very
enemy immediately and there's something
really nice about that but it's it's
also you know having a child in the mix
just totally it just it just totally you
know gives you an immediate anchor point
for why you'd care about it and there's
kind of those like required moments that
I sort of talked about you know those
moments that you see everywhere in all
of those types of stories there too you
know you've got the especially stories
where the parent parental figure kind of
grows into the appearance I really love
that
get them going there yeah and we should
have enough for a third town center what
I'll try and do
just in case they come around that
direction I don't think they will but
they they they they sometimes go weird
weird directions but usually usually
they are the AI comes in like a straight
line towards your base why can I not
build there if the AI is has built
it's it's just a it's a particular it's
a it's a particular trope that just
instantly moves me and I I know it's
like it's a really shallow and I'm kind
of in one way but I love it all right
you guys we we have too much gold for
the moment and no Age of Empires player
has ever said that but I need more food
you know I'd have always really wanted
to do is just have like an army of monks
just like a hundred monks and see how
much
people sort of like like I mean I I
really love the story just because and
if anyone criticizes my farm placement I
swear
the people sort of criticize the game
Detroit become human I mean for a lot of
reasons which I won't get into here but
they well are the one I want to get into
is that they said that basically only
one of the three stories because you
play from three different perspectives
it's immersive but I I just totally
disagree like I loved Cara's story Cara
being the character that you played from
one of the perspective charities okay
too much once again too much too much
woods not enough food
I mean I am spending like my food yeah
see they'd be music Imperial edge this
is this is why Oh
this is bad this is very bad this is
this is so horrendous ly bad
I completely forgot about leaving my
dudes there okay wow I really screwed
that one up
but they're fleeing now yeah that was my
fault
guys we need to just go back there and
raid but because otherwise the the do
you have like they're just not very good
that these guys here they're really good
for taking our buildings but they're
they're really not good
luckily castles just
take out these things like nothing else
okay okay okay I'm heading to the I'm
heading to the Imperial edge guys I'm
going I'm going
try try and K being distracted in this
game is not easy but they will pretty
much have to take out my they will
basically have to take out my two
castles here before they will ever take
out
let's sell a bunch of my gold
a bunch of my wood and let's get a lot
of nights and then okay let's let's try
the a more efficient rating party guys
let's try again alright let's I'll stick
it with you the whole time
and we'll just just go and burn down
some buildings because the point is that
you destroy things before they get to
you pretty disappointed talkin number 23
all right let's put just Royce I'm
giving up reducing facilities basically
you try and get out of there before they
even notice that you're destroying their
their buildings
see so far they it has not triggered a
counter-attack kill some killer see
they're useless at killing units I mean
it took it they took like five hits to
take out a villager I mean these are
villages the weakest units in the game
so well we'll see about No
see lots of lots of gold still but the
point is
oh oh I left it too long so now they've
got their freaking pikemen coming after
me pikemen are super good against
cavalry I don't think there's ever been
like a conspiracy story with like a
parental storyline cuz that'll be cool
you know that would that would hit my
fancy perfectly that would be better be
just what I love
all right let's let's do that and you do
that once again running out of food I'm
getting chased by a lion I can kill them
okay let's kill the lion useless useless
and then we'll get some trivia shares go
and because trebuchet is really
important and I need to take out that
castle
that'll be basically what I'll try and
do is I'm gonna try and scene units
forward to take out that castle with a
bunch of Units defending the tribute
show which will be able to take it out
from afar while I hit them from the rear
doing while I had them from the rear
doing with with Tarkan's that's that's
the aim at least
okay okay we got we seem to be doing
okay they are ahead of me in points but
you know I think that those stories
where you know you've got that kind of
father daughter or father son or mother
daughter and mother son kind of viable
then mother son I have not seen very
much I'm a pop cap so that means a comic
any more units I they just make me feel
so much you know they they just get me
in a way that that a lot of other
stories don't I need to get a university
hello my girlfriend just arrived home
but hi I'm in the middle of a recording
yeah oh no oh oh that's bad that's very
bad bad bad bad get out get out get out
let's just just leave that leave that
hellhole
not good
I need to get up I need to get get like
a alright cuz once a good now they
should be good enough to 300 feet 200
gold your food guys that it's not what
you want to do I know first that was bad
ok ok well at least I got them to
retreat I'm gonna need to really I'm
gonna need I'm gonna need to stock up on
cars arches cavalry artists include I
don't know if that includes
Spearman I don't know if them clues the
arches but yeah people often see the car
is story and Detroit become human was
like the least interesting but I I I
just I've really loved it that was my
favorite story I played through the game
with three with two out of friends and
we sort of took control of a particular
one particular storyline and I took
control of I took car and I loved it it
was so moving and people often think
that you know the fact that the
character is taking you know taking
control of taking care of a younger
character means that they this sort of
stifled or whatever but I just I don't
agree alright lets it sit these guys to
guard him these guys to go out here and
we'll set him to God and oh you idiots
okay fine fine
and but I don't know to me it just it it
just really heightens my emotional
attachment
all right take out take out the unit
producing so this is reducing siege
weapons which I haven't seen any of just
yet good now let's get you on nope drop
the drop the door you guys are not
equipped for this
okay let's draw let's draw them into
into the Castle fire so they're
following me here which means that they
are not defending these guys here so
Polly we control them into this little
trap good and now they're probably gonna
reappear along yeah which is just what I
want
cuz I'll bring them back in along here
Oh
geez why do you guys run forwards
oh shoot
so you gotta take you gotta take out
their tribute shades or they'll destroy
you but I have a feeling that I've just
lost all of my units so I'm retreating
then back to and nope nope okay well
look I did a good amount of damage I did
I did decent amount of damage and that's
that's all you can ask for in this world
that is all you can ask for in this
world I'm running out of wood this is
this is not good
this is very uncalled the other goods go
bad
okay that is a lot of talk ins guys no
more cold this is bad that is all the
gold I've got which means we're into
trash units that's fine that's fine
I can handle this which means these are
really all the talking's I have okay
what's another trope that I really love
so I've got conspiracy stories and I've
got kind of that mother-daughter
father-son thing and I think I really
love I love seeing I love seeing like
the usually calm loving characters like
let loose and struggle with kind of
violence I think that is a really cool
thing let you see this you see it in
come on you you heal that pop gets
reached okay what
all right we'll send you guys forward
and you can you can mind you can mine
there all right hit them from the side
again two different two different angles
oh you cool bastards are stuck there
that's actually really annoying
no no do not you don't want to bring
bring your people onto Castle fire I
really love seeing you know like Katara
let loose in the southern Raiders it's
part of the reason I it you know it's
one of my favorite episodes that there's
just a real reveal of their character
what's that that's a town center
this seemed that way bring them right up
to here
they're still beating me on the points
okay I'm just gonna lose a bunch of
tacos against these castles but I really
need to take them out they're just too
much okay
I'm losing like old my talk ins but
it'll it'll be worth it to take out a
couple of good causes because they
shouldn't have the stone to replace it
or out
okay we've got a bunch more that's good
30 but my drive 30 idle
okay oh shoot see they don't like coming
under castle fire and they know to
retreat instantly I tell you what I do
need
I probably should have actually
collected the relics
now I'll see you off let's just sing you
up that way okay oh crap I have a lot of
I didn't realize I had so many trebuchet
to be honest that's that's really my
fault and I need to get
that was really stupid of me to get so
many tribute shows but here I am getting
lots of trivia shows
it's just
suddenly being very bad
no I don't want any more trippy shades
[Music]
it's I actually haven't written any
stories that reflect either of these
tropes either I mean I'm kind of like
too but every time I've kind of come up
with a kind of conspiracy story that I'd
like to tell it's kind of like I am just
sort of using the tropes without being
you know really thinking about what I'm
saying
and you know I don't know I just I
haven't got a meaningful story to tell
that that's about those tropes yes I
will one day maybe but the day is not
this day okay talking's alright all
right boys let's go
let's send them to the front this is the
First World War guys what are you even
doing here
one day I'll tell a story that combines
those chirps but I haven't got an evil
story to tell and you know that's that's
kind of high right like I I can't just
pick up a cool idea a cool concept and
go oh yeah yeah that'll be fun to write
about and then do it I just don't have
that in me because I need like a deeper
concept to abide by then than that and I
I just don't okay time to build a castle
right on their doorstep
I completely forgot about my talking's
so they're all they're all gonna die
and a lot of castles goodness
Oh
let's I may have bitten off more than I
could chew with this I may have done
that
all right sending sending all these guys
to their dance
they don't need life life is
was so like
I need to get more units
oh I have a bunch of units in which
about to lose all the tributaries
what are they elite unit or
this is very bad
all right just lost my castle and all of
me units that fell upon that really
badly collapsed nope nope nope nope nope
crap this is bad this is bad this game
has gone very badly all of a sudden
17,000 okay
this is this is very Unger
and they're destroying all of my
buildings
see what I need to do is they've just
got the range on me like all I can shoot
it oh look and all I can send at them as
skirmishers
and that's just not enough for the
moment
I'm sorry I'm really distracted I am not
very good at multitasking see this is
this is what happens i I've lost both my
castles these freakin oh oh that's
really annoying freakin on pod cannons
that's what that's what that's what this
is about
I'm out of wood I keep sending units to
wood okay all of you all of you on wood
yeah I'm afraid of possibly lost this
game like I just I can't produce units
fast enough we've got these freakin
czars I'm sorry
I'm sorry this is the end of me I've got
nothing nothing left
but I I was in such a good position and
I just didn't control my units well
enough well I tried I tried I just they
wouldn't get how much did I how much
damage did I do
let's have a look at the stats they
outclassed me and in a prett thing
usually they can beat hard a eyes but
trying to talk about stuff at the same
time it's not easy I think like the
emotional connection in those stories
about the parent-child you know kind of
thing trying to escape it just they're
just so real and so visceral and so
natural to feel that you know you don't
spend any time kind of getting used to
the characters you can place yourself in
it immediately so you just place
yourself in and immediately and then it
carries it with you carries it with
through the story the whole way through
military wow they did they did a lot
better than me I did not actually expect
that buildings raised I did destroy more
buildings and I did lose fewer buildings
because I gave up before they could I
did clean more food than them but they
got more of everything than me by a wide
margin in wood which is you know where
they were outclassing me I suppose I
just didn't have the Hassad to counter
them with all the upgrades to it I beat
them to everything except the Imperial
age they did have a lot of castles they
were sort of screwing me see look at
this
I I might have had the military
advantage but I just suddenly lost it
like I I pushed I shouldn't have pushed
my trebuchet forward that last
with just nothing to defend them I
thought they weren't gonna be able to
sort of seen stuff a burden I just did
it was there so that was that was my
fault
I'm very sorry maybe I'll win next time
who knows on the next episode do you
want to help me you know decide the
questions the patrons will be doing that
and yeah I'm sorry for my rambling I'm
sorry for being so distracted I'm just
I'm not used to doing this sort of thing
I don't know how people otherwise do it
but I will try better to do it in the
future it's all about practice people
it's all about practice all right stay
nerdy and I'll see you in the future